okay people who are joining this
livestream we are talking about
incremental language development fourth
language as we head into the version
12.1 release some of what we're talking
about as for that and summers for after
that okay monitors as a headdress okay
let me explain what I'm did is it
obvious what I'm talking about or is
that no that's why we wanted to ask you
okay so with monitor you know I can say
things like monitor you know table you
know pause point Oh on or something um
you know I can do something like this
right yep where I can see that but if
I'm doing a map I don't have any way to
monitor it if I say map this over you
know range of a thousand there's no
monitoring for that so what I'm
wondering is whether there's a headdress
approach to that where we can say
monitored
well I wonder what there is I mean the
thing that has worked really well as
echo you know echo is really useful and
it would be really wonderful if we could
have a way to I mean a monitor you know
in a sense one of the things that's bad
I know where the monitor has a curried
form does monitor have a curried form it
does not interesting because one of the
things I think will be useful there is
to be able to say monitor of I
at table bla bla bla bla bla just like
you can say echo at table see what I'm
saying yep but it was a case like math
what would we write sort of monitoring
well I mean I have a pro a thing called
parallel map monitored which is either
in the function repository or about to
be in the function repository it's very
useful and I think there's a number of
things in the function repository that a
monitored map monitored versions of map
um I agree that it is not obvious how
you know I mean it would require
internal code work to be able to show
the monitoring of the map I mean we
could show the index of the element we
are at the moment or the element itself
I think we want to show the index I
think the best thing would be the ending
I mean I think in a perfect world we
will have choice of what to show but I
think showing the index is already very
useful I mean why not apply a function
to the you know - why not have a map
index style you know hash one hash two
thing and the default would just be hash
- right good for our echo function which
allows you to choose what to print sure
yes exactly but I mean echo function the
problem with echo with respect to this
is echo has the goods right there it has
the main payload right there and you can
basically just say you know in it then
it's just having a side-effect the
difficulty here is that I don't know how
we get into the innards I mean what we
would have to do for monitor them of
that is we would have to decorate F
right with the monitoring code which is
not the most impossible thing in the
world to do right in a sense it's like
changing math to map indexed and
changing F to echo the index right so in
other words it would do a transformation
that monitored a map would turn into map
indexed of something or another right
and yeah go ahead the other thing I was
thinking about is that
we need an echo that can't replace the
previous echo so that we don't get a
million acres printed oh yeah yeah we
needs to be a temporary cell just like
monitor is yes
I mean monitor creates a temporary cell
and then does its business but the point
is that what we would have to do with
monitored is
well honestly um
you know the better thing to do would be
if we were able to say monitor at and
then the whole map thing we were able to
just say that in other words have a 1
argument form of monitor that just
monitors with respect to whatever it can
monitor with respect to so that you can
insert it just like you insert echo
right uh I mean the thing about echo
that really I like very much is that you
know I mean I use it all the time and
you know I just put it in print stuff
out I use echo function occasionally I
realized that I I need to look up how to
put labels with echo I assume I can just
put a label yeah it's the second
argument I see but that means that I
have to go and actually write echo you
know that I have to do this
echo hash label right what they
typically do is just writing the echo
around the object I want to print in the
label if you have code with an X just
rubbed that thing thing this echo komali
bow no no I understand that's what I do
but I I what I usually do is I put echo
at sign I just insert echo at sign in my
code I see um which I find you know I
find that really useful and it will be
great if I could just put monitor in my
code and have it monitor you know do
something reasonable I mean the
difficulty is echo it's very well to
find what it does it's taking the result
right monitor it will be less well
defined has to reach inside the system
to be able to you know figure out what
to do I mean and we'd have to support it
function by function so to speak I mean
each function would have to get some
kind of rewrite that would have monitor
would have to rewrite the function to
something and unfortunately might lead
to different bugs the various comments
on our live stream Ethan says it'd be
nice to have monitor work with parallel
things yeah I've noticed that issue
recently I don't really know why it
doesn't work I mean you know the thing
that I've been using which I've at least
privately put in the function repository
is split up um I think it's supposed to
go in the main function repository but I
think it has a conflict with another
thing
that's there let me see if I can pull
this up
as the sky I would see
you
statically badly documented but Tim oh
it's really pathetic here but if I do
yeah I do have it set up here parallel
map monitored but say F range of 10,000
or something it might happen rather
quickly here you'll see Oh drat um
see what I can do here let's do a rain
let's do a pause point
Oh point one range of a thousand here or
something okay now watch what it does
okay starting parallel map see that
so it's giving me a fraction complete
it's given me the fact you know fraction
of things and then it's giving me an ETA
that it's computed nice it's kind of
nice right and I didn't write this but
max wrote it and it's I think the only
reason isn't in the function repository
right now is some conflict with another
monitor thing in the function repository
which might be worth looking at as well
let me just see what's there
I'm happy when the new search system for
the function repository exists um
one of the download I thought
to something else a parallel monitor
okay we got various comments here on the
live stream so first thing is making one
or two work with parallel stuff so I
don't know how parallel mat monitor
works actually and I don't know why
monitor doesn't work with parallel
things and I mean I guess there's a
question a monitor parallel table see
what happens if I say monitor parallel
table
you
you
and that is pathetic right right
yeah that's pathetic that that is a bug
of some kind I mean I don't know why
that why that fails but we should you
know ask Roman I guess about that um
okay let's let's take a look at some of
these other cons here wrapper around
irritable things that provides a
progress bar yeah well that's what we're
talking about here basically um
it's just not easy to understand what's
you know what is iterative you know what
what counts as an iterator I mean it we
already have monitor for things with
named iterators um
you
okay we have a bunch of interest
just ensued on the livestream let me go
through them here Carl says
um
complains that net train has such a nice
UX and map does not yeah well fair
enough
I mean net train of course has a minimum
sort of minimum operation that's much
more complicated than map so the fact
that there's overhead associated with
building a giant UI is irrelevant
compared to the effort it has to spend
doing the training whereas if every map
had to build a giant UI would be it
would be bad
um okay so dynamic map
you
okay nice makes
so that makes them deface almost worthy
of
Oh
so really minor thing but ah what is
this doing why is that saying
information panel um that the font for
this click here to update is really not
consistent with the other stuff here
darling maybe that's for you to try to
try to um click here to update let's see
if it updated
and why didn't it tell me it updated if
it did update now it's a most recent
version was already downloaded so that
was bad the click here to update should
should just either disappear or should
do something when the update has
occurred not just sit there telling me
to update again make sense
yeah
okay I still think this isn't right it's
where's the information tunnel it
doesn't it's not generating it's not
displaying correctly right there seems
to be expecting that function to work
the information panel and information
panel yeah
I don't even know I've never heard of
information panel well anyway so perhaps
that could be separately investigated I
think it is the the expert on
information panel yeah okay um Ali is
complaining that we don't have a
numerical gradient or laplacian function
I agree that is a bit surprising we
actually had an ND very very long ago
that that's a separate thing let's put
that put that and put that recycle that
onto the back of this list cuz when
we're talking about different things
right now okay Wow okay there is a
laplacian by calling nd solve mesh okay
well that's a that's a separate issue
it's a separate issue but can-can is
that for Devon who can bring that up
yeah yeah that that is numerical
laplacian goes to roger it would not be
the first time that we have functions
where we've solved the hard problem but
haven't solved the haven't exposed the
easy problem okay um so nice progress
function but it's doing what I would
like okay package for science on github
by Mathematica for science I do not know
this I mean I've heard of this and I
have not looked at it so perhaps
somebody else could look at it here um
what is well TQ DM is apparently a
Python package which maybe somebody
could look at um Sandra is suggesting
that this dynamic mapping thing could be
an option for parallel map it'd be nice
if there was a jus more general wrapper
for doing this and a way of adding and
subtracting monitoring that was as easy
as the adding and subtracting echo act
um
I stole ush is suggesting things about
table with a monitored range I don't
know why the monitored would be put
there I mean that's a that's a I don't
know why that would go there I don't see
why that makes sense
um I don't think it's gonna help it
terribly much I think it needs to see
centrally well I don't think the
evaluation I think by the time it's
evaluated yeah I don't really see
consuming those things it's it's easier
to handle the monitoring centrally than
to handle it when it consumes every
elements I think
dynamic that is what people want here
okay even his commenting it doesn't work
into our point why would you think what
we're observing here um yeah yeah well
right so the suggestion from Carla's
have map and things show this after some
amount of time I think the issue here is
um I see a Cell USA just suggesting that
this thing with putting the monitor
around the range would do something
about creating an iterator not sure how
that would work I'll try that will work
I don't think that's the way the problem
is that a lot of times we don't have an
explicit iterator like in the map case
whether if somebody has a very seashell
seashore like background sound there now
the seashore went away
um the
um
okay so let's let's return to this for a
second so if we could do it the
possibility of something where we say
monitor of map bla bla bla bla bla
people think would be good now the only
thing that's weird here is this is a one
level monitor in a sense that what it
will be doing is it will be saying take
that function that I see here
immediately before me and monitor it so
for example if we had something like a
list of maps
we would not expect that to work that is
that would merely be monitoring the list
where it has little to say
making sense which is why I had
suggested a headdress type thing
you
what would be the case if we were to say
monitored if there was a um is there any
one of these that would let's see what
would that do that would make that would
do the right thing wouldn't it monitored
a map so if I do F star G of X right
what does that actually compute what
does that do that that is equivalent to
this no it's not that's that what do I
need to do here if it is some
what would that do
that
oh I see I see I see I see this is kind
of trivial so obviously what it actually
is is F of G of X but that requires
those parentheses and then it would do
that
my gosh and Python looks like cool
processors
I don't even understand that piece of
code um
but this is for parallel
mutation which is a little different um
oh yeah okay um
oh well that helps um
okay I think someone else needs to try
to understand this but okay back to the
back to the original question so one
question is implementational e how would
we even imagine that it would work with
things like map would they rewrite the
map and then go and evaluate would we
modify the internal code of map what
would happen thoughts do me the simplest
thing is to change their functions to
just rewrite it as in rewrite it on the
fly like like the monitor of map would
not evaluate and that this would then
turn it so let's imagine that we've got
this and then this turns into I mean
let's imagine just for the sake of
argument that that actually turns into
you know this this some
you
dynamic map of effort whatever it's a
little scary and it might make code do
different things right but you know
that's why a headdress would be
semantically clean because one could
imagine
family of monitored functions as in they
know what to do with what they've been
given because I mean for example what's
a good example let's say let me give you
another example
okay monitored array what would you like
it to do not completely silly operation
you know you've got a giant array
but for example yeah I mean I think this
will be reporting there the positioning
the rate at which it is working at the
moment yeah I agree I agree but I mean
so the way that would have to work is
each one of these each one of these
monitored whatever things would need
custom code that goes and recreates
array essentially throw monitoring date
throw monitor info of the function of
hash like this okay here's another
question this metaphor here of throw
monitoring info we don't really have
that metaphor so in other words if we
said if we had something that said
monitor
yeah I mean the difficulty is this thing
needs to know how much there is to do
right so it can't be purely local to
this
right Disney it's a whole infrastructure
I think there was a project at some
point on trying to modernize all the
monitor yes maybe Devon can say
something to that who is becoming that
now that's me and we actually have a
meeting next Friday about it which
includes you to go over Julio's
framework for standardizing progress
monitoring but she's currently working
on great so if we do one of these things
it should plug into that framework yes
by the way we should live stream that
meeting I think other people by budget
interesting sure I can suggest it um all
right I think we have to move off this
topic but clearly there's a bunch to do
here and let's let's bring this up again
in that meeting about the progress
monitoring framework okay
okay yes so these this was another
question you formulated recently about
the relation between mean around and
other around objects and so here try to
explain what's going on and at the end
that is sorry an extension suggested so
yeah can you go up a bit to the previous
formulas okay so the PSU that I had is
if we take mean so if we if we do let's
say you know random real
you
humanists chanting what I mean I mean
list keep it like a table okay and if I
say mean of this it goes in and does the
column you know whatever you want to
call them it does the it just adds up
the all of these right and then now but
now if I were to put in around numbers
here it doesn't know no way to me I was
trying to do mean around that's if you
do mean around this is get the same
vector plus the Cavani on this
information right because what this what
this is saying is that that mean is
correlated it's a vector with
correlation information which is in the
correlation in insulin that college
American Finance matrix in the second
argument why didn't I get that well I
tried this a few days ago is this new no
no this way how did I get something that
had well okay what about if those are
random integers sensing well I was okay
now the things that are so the thing I
thought you were worried about is the
fact that the covariance matrix is
divided by the number of objects because
this is the covariance is not about the
distribution itself but about the mean
of the distribution no I was confused by
something vastly simpler than that which
was that when I did this somehow it
didn't give the result but it didn't
give this result it seemed like me
around wasn't working on lists but it
seems to be working just fine yes yes
it's supposed to realize I'm working on
lists so I have to use vector around I
mean if it took a list of integers is
written around scale so this is quite
beautiful and by the way you should show
the work flow in the documentation from
the mean of those things mean around of
those things
- the around which then ignores the
cupboards
exactly takes two diagonal elements
that's beautiful
okay so what are you proposing over here
right so the the other thing here is the
difference between a round of a list of
numbers a mini round of that same list
of numbers which already works for for
around and and touched a little back to
our one right if I say one two three
here yes so what this is doing is so if
you take a round of a distribution what
we agreed is that that would take the
mean and the normal distribution now
most of the statistics functions are
able to handle distributions and lists
of numbers that represent a realization
of the distribution uh-huh so around us
the same thing
so around is going to say oh not has
worked I am really this is cool this
works well that's fitting a Gaussian and
then extracting the values okay so it's
mean around gonna give the same result
no exactly so that's the difference I
wanted to discuss
so what mean around means is that it's
computing the mean and then it's giving
you the uncertainty of the mean itself
which is the certainty of the original
divided by the square root of of the
number of projects so if you keep adding
more and more elements distributed in
the same way the around will stay but
the mean around will get more and more
precise because as you have more
elements the mean gets more precised
okay so you're saying if I do this and
then I say a hundred of those okay
let's say I do a thousand of those
except it's much more okay whereas
you're saying if I just do the around of
that
that's getting to more and more
precisely but it's - what's ours - no
matter how many entertain numbers you
have I see I see that makes perfect
sense this looks just exactly right so
vector around is able to do partially
the same thing but not they like the
last thing you have their doctor around
cannot do it so I which a lot of very
last that one so a round of a multi
normal distribution
sorry vector around of a multi normal
distribution should work okay I think
that's a corner case I think it's cool
to make it work but I think that's I had
no idea of this work it's a natural
extension of having around working on on
distributions because if you go to the
page of I know standard deviation it
works ball draw on distribution span
lists
it's the third interpreted as a list no
but it's not listed in this in here this
is X 1 X 2 X 3 X 4 right this is a
distribution
I don't think it's listed here this
threads over the list but you don't give
the one argument form of the X sub eyes
yes I thought it was kind of implicitly
included in the distribution case but I
certainly didn't figure that out um I
think you should flip around the round
of s then a round of dist and then the
last one is a round of X 1 X 2 X 3 it's
great
I wish we had support for a round in
more places is Goshen working on it that
is that I mean getting it in this in the
fitting functions and things is the next
important thing right I think not yet
she's busy with phantom serious
statistics ok three new ways of wrapping
okay yeah so this is three parallel
discussions we are having and I think
they are very related and we need to
understand what operation is so one is
the discussion on 3rd mm-hmm
the other one is something we started
last week with what we call list applied
which I think it could be very useful
for our transformation functions which
take lists rather than yes so what's the
tip what is the so the idea it's just
like reverse applied where you take this
and it gives this so you're saying list
applied
you
there's a bit of code on the left okay I
see it and by the way we've now also got
operator applied so here
you
you
hmmm I agree this is quite interesting
quite useful to have um
let me just think about this for a
second so the whole point is this list
applied on its own like that is
equivalent to F of
this isn't it yes but arguably the list
applied form is more readable so here I
see so you could then give it's like you
don't have to put the list around the
elements I mean unfortunately there's
the sort of unlist applied version too
well that supply isn't it
yes exactly the kind of parent of all
applied functions as apply itself which
does that right so this is an inverse of
apply list applied as an inverse of
apply in a sense it wraps with a list
okay
there were a couple of questions about a
round from our livestream car was saying
he expects around to be a normal
distribution around the middle but
that's not strictly the case well it is
the case that you can just say a round
of the normal distribution but there's a
whole long story about the extent to
which around isn't really a normal
distribution it's something with its own
separate calculus because it can't
follow the whole story of the
distribution but yes you can do that I'm
sure if I say if I put in here something
like you know a Weibull distribution or
something um what is it gonna do here is
it going to use the mean and standard
deviation of that distribution yes oh
wow that's release 50 what is that doing
yeah for some distributions it realizes
they are asymmetric and then it does
what what is that what are those
asymmetric things what are the computers
moments of the distribution somehow yes
they are computed from the distribution
itself but what is that mean the
previous thing with its variance wasn't
it the plus/minus in the in the normal
distribution case was the variance of
the normal distribution wasn't it yes
and this is also variance it's also how
can I be very interpret a symmetric like
that I don't remember the exact formula
and I can look it up what's the proper
way of doing this it's computed this
it's not something that is pretty fine
for it's the situation right
second
you
okay
I be clear so that's how that
touch coordinates
what is this
you
oh my gosh what is this doing
yes yes so the idea here is that we get
an array of data it could be also
potentially dates these are really
indices out there I mean this is really
like map indexed this is Ilias prepared
but indexed yes by default but then the
second argument can rescale those
synthesis and then we could say I don't
know if we have an innovation array it
corresponds to these Lots and this one's
right right I mean it's a skill and in
principle we could have a third argument
which is something about how the things
are packaged in here I mean it's depend
packaging so I mean this is a variant of
map index somehow yes we have a function
to map you know what to do in that sense
well we do in fact have our function map
but it's being given as a sort of
footnote third argument because I mean I
can imagine cases where what you really
want here is a rescale you know
something arrow see those people are
commenting on around by the way is it in
fact true that a round of the list of
numbers is equivalent to a round of
empirical distribution of those numbers
mmm probably not because in a roundel is
always this Gaussian assumption and I
can imagine empirical distribution will
try to fit to other distributions
maybe we should for the properties and
relations around we should figure out
what's true um
Sandra is saying that linear model fit
should should handle around numbers yes
indeed indeed indeed indeed um okay
let's go back to this all right so let's
let's review these so pad is about
paired is a is a special case no pet is
not a special case paired paired is a
little bit like the attached coordinates
idea exactly yeah to me these are three
of years in which we have data and we
wrap a list but they fill it with other
stuff around it and so it has the
impression that we are after after
something bigger yeah
well so where does the data come from
some cases it's just yours wrap the list
in other cases it is an indexed version
of that where the list you're wrapping
contains
you know there's something there's a
there's a greeting card inside the
wrapping paper or something you're
putting something else in there inside
the wrapping actually there isn't no
that this doesn't have additional
wrapping in the same sense that list
applied has additional wrapping this is
this is simply this is packaging each
element here and I don't even know what
level number it goes to and so on that's
a separate issue well it it's realizing
that this is a rectangular array up to
level two and then going there and then
the example at the end has a third
argument in which we could put multiple
things and in this case it's just a rule
it's no I understand which would which
would otherwise be prepared or something
which should otherwise be normally that
would be basically append to hash to
assuming that's the index hash one which
is the element or if we were going to be
really spiffy this would be reverse
applied of app and
all right that's it right um I suppose
to that okay um okay
mine is asking will attach coordinates
work with images video and audio I don't
understand how in certain information in
yeah I mean what we have there is this
the UM
I think it's processing sorry they use
the data range option and that's a way
of specifying that range that
corresponds to the two axis range for
what purpose I mean that's for for the
equivalent of map indexed and so on
alright for example an image
transformation your function may be
working on a space which is not directly
the space of their pixels so by
specifying date arranged to come up one
space to right but I thought but it's
not annotating the object itself with
the coordinates with the indices okay
but in our
you
well
mapping paired yeah I agree I agree I
agree
mapping prepared I think not Intel is
going to be the most frequent case and
it's very useful right
yeah that's very useful
now it's it's like attaching the
coordinates to the wrench mud helps yeah
I understand
okay what's the generalization of pair
the wrapping had which is that yeah so
you do suggested to have it in the first
argument here I would prefer to have it
the last argument to follow for example
would inert us yeah but then I was
worried about the evaluation this is the
rotten head subsection so which of these
two results would be the right result
[Music]
you
you
I think the first one is much more
useful result but I'm not Shh well if we
use a folding function why would we use
it there yeah right right because it may
be that had an ex don't evaluate
themselves Butthead effect stats I'm not
sure that's a separate issue but let's
talk about the relationship between this
construct
you
yeah so what would happen if I say
indexed pad
of F onto range of 10
oh I see it was fed too
stuff but it's not obvious to me that
that's right that it was fed too much
stuff
some things it yeah that's what I'm
thinking I'm thinking this is very much
like the attach coordinates business
right because this
um
yeah coming from our live stream from SW
SH around could be treated like low
level numbers with torn algebra like
complex numbers absolutely that's what
Jose spent a large amount of time
thinking about absolutely it has its own
elaborate axioms basically um and I
looked at the code what it's doing is
that for a round of a distribution
computes the median and the mean of the
distribution and based on that decides
whether it's a symmetric or asymmetric
distribution and if it is a symmetric
then it will do a quantile computation
with the same numbers as the standard
Sigma for normal distributions and
that's why this is a this is a
definition that goes continuously to the
symmetric distinction makes sense
sounds good okay look let's look at this
thing and we have to break in a minute
and actually four people on this live
stream we're about to start another live
stream about Pacolet public packet
repository I need to get a bit of
chocolate and in between but which I
think people might find of interest and
we'd be interested in people's feedback
on um
let's see but let's just address this
for one more moment here so I mean this
is the question of what is the
relationship between this paired
function and so normally with the single
map here this becomes that right now
with the map indexed
we've got both the range of 10 was our
range from 10 to 20 then the numbers
would have to be the positions and so
that's right but but in the map indexed
that would do that but then this would
be different yes indeed right so in your
attache coordinates you're you know
you're basically using the I mean
there's different emphasis here because
here there's an F being wrapped around
each thing here this is a purely the F
is identity but you're packaging in the
map indexed indices right in this case
using the reverse applied append here a
zero point so so we have several
functions which are particular cases of
their of a single operation which is
like if that's coordinates but mapping a
function at the same time that's right
I don't understand the unified version
of this but and it's possible that there
are two different defaults that are both
useful I mean I think the paired
function is clearly useful and
right but it doesn't know so paired
could perfectly well take as a hash too
so to speak
it's
yeah I mean if what it did
I'm
a little confused about this
we need to go to the next meeting but
let's let's start the next point of the
series but talking about this issue I
think we're making some progress here um
the okay I encourage you are you coming
to the the packet repository meeting
Jose I'm not it's not okay um the okay
let's wrap this up alright so we'll be
at this other meeting in just a moment
here um thanks thanks guys